all right Fred I thought a great place
for us to start our conversation here
would be around this idea of vertically
integrated technology stack that's
something that you all hang your hat on
and are very proud to kind of take this
uh very unique approach in the Bitcoin
mining space explain what a vertically
integrated technology stack is and then
why you all feel so confident that this
is the right strategy for you
so if you think about how Apple has
developed their whole ecosystem around
the iPhone they own the cloud software
they own a lot of the core apps they own
the operating system and the phone they
own the silicon and the phone and they
own a lot of the distribution medium if
you take that analogy to Bitcoin mining
we have our own pool that we operate we
don't participate in a third-party pool
why well if we're operating in our own
pool our pool doesn't have to be
designed to deal with a lot of
third-party Miners and dealing with
people logging in and security and how
do you make sure that a miner connecting
to your pool is actually supposed to be
there plus
as third party pools you have to be
prepared to take s9s s19s hashes from
all sorts of machines we have two
machines running in our pool in our
Fleet today it's s19j pros and it's XPS
that's all we have to worry about so we
can optimize the pool to be super
efficient
and by efficiency it's communication
latency things like that so we can pull
out a nanosecond here a couple
milliseconds here it just makes it more
efficient then we run our own uh
operating system our own firmware in our
miners more and more today we're in the
process of rolling it out across our
whole Fleet but the site we built in UAE
is built Soup To Nuts on our own stack
and so by using our own firmware it
means we can overclock we can under
clock we can adjust the exact
performance of the minor specific to the
environmental conditions the energy
pricing whatever's going on wherever we
happen to be so we get more efficiency
gains there plus because we control the
firmware most miners have bloatware in
them
so if you think about it the average
Miner has to have all the software it
needs in it so it can run standalone
well if you're running 200 000 miners
connecting to your own pool you need
very little firmware actually in the
miner and so we can strip out a bunch of
stuff that again takes up clock Cycles
it uses more electricity and allows us
to operate that Miner more efficiently
we have our own controller boards which
allow us to do a number of things on the
miner and in our immersion solution
we've co-developed the immersion
technology so we can fine-tune the minor
and the immersion system together so now
you have this whole system from the
operating system in the cloud for the
pool all the way down to the minor the
firmware in it and the immersion plus we
also made an investment last year in a
company called oradine which is really
designing the Next Generation uh Bitcoin
miner it's a U.S firm designed by
engineers in Silicon Valley an amazing
product
um that'll be coming to the market this
year and so there the reason for that
was we needed a couple of things one is
bit main uh while they make a good
product they have 60 70 market share
it's almost a monopoly
and that's a high risk issue if the U.S
and China get involved in a trade War
there could be supply issues so we
needed to make sure there was a U.S
manufacturer more importantly we wanted
to be able to adjust the performance of
a miner all the way down to the
individual Asic level because in times
of high energy costs or high temperature
we needed to be able to tweak The Miner
all the way down at the Asic level and
we wanted the miner to be configured in
a way so we could do industrial scale
mining with blades as opposed to using
the shoe boxes that everybody else uses
and so we needed to have access to
custom designing The Miner so think of
us more like apple and how they address
things than how traditional miners do so
that's the nature of the vertical
technology stack what's fascinating to
me is you basically are trying to reduce
diversification in this technology stack
and that you want control right you want
the centralization in your geography
approach though you are seeking
diversification and kind of trying to go
all around the world talk a little bit
about that specific strategy
sure so um
most minors tend to locate um
trying to build a large site for
economic economies of scale right in one
location well that makes you subject to
two things climatology and Regulatory
and grid pricing right so if you look at
um you know all the people that operate
in Texas and we have considerable sites
in Texas now you're subject to aircot
you're subject to the climate in Texas
you know we're going right now into
summertime here and as we're recording
this in June uh we're having some of the
hottest days of the year so that's
impacting performance so by having
Geographic diversity in the U.S you
separate yourself from uh issues
specific to one grid operator you
separate yourself from
um climate specifically so we're in
Texas and North Dakota opposite ends of
the country right different types of
climates
lets us operate very differently at the
same time by moving offshore and our
partnership in the UA is the first
example of this we're also creating
diversification away from the U.S
which you never know from a regulatory
perspective may or may not be important
at some point in the future but most
importantly for us it was the ability to
partner with a sovereign wealth fund who
controls the energy generation the
energy distribution and the land and the
government regulations in a way that
allows us to have the ideal partner so
that we're sure about our energy costs
for the full term of this agreement we
are you know we've nailed the energy
cost
um we have the benefit of it being
um
fully offset with Rex It's a combination
of natural gas and nuclear energy over
the life of the agreement
um and they invested enough capital in
this so they have so much skin in the
game so it's really critical for them to
make this successful now the benefit of
this kind of poster child installation
in the UAE
is that now we have other countries
coming to us uh people in Qatar coming
to us saying hey Marathon we'd love for
you to mine here Oman hey Marathon we
want you to come here Bhutan hey we want
you to come here countries in Latin
America countries in Africa we're
looking at geothermal opportunities so
now these opportunities are starting to
come to us because we think of it as
your technology company you just won the
perfect reference customer as your
partner and so people want to come to
you because they say well if you can
work with these guys and you can do this
then you obviously are serious you're
well capitalized and so we believe we're
very well positioned to continue to grow
internationally to the point where we'll
have about 50 of our mining capacity
outside of the U.S 50 in the U.S
so you mentioned nuclear power and
that's something that I think people
have always dreamed about is like why
don't we hook this up to those types of
power generation uh facilities what are
you seeing on that front is that
something that you think will become the
standard do you think that it's still
kind of Fringe idea where are we
so uh it varies by region
um you know in the U.S uh and generally
speaking in the developed world after
Three Mile Island Chernobyl uh and
fukushiyama there's been this kind of
fear about nuclear energy
um the Ukraine crisis and the energy
crisis that came from that got people to
kind of revisit that and we now have
things like smrs small modular nuclear
reactors the difference between smrs and
the traditional large-scale nuclear
reactors is for one thing they're
um not one-offs you're making the same
nuclear reactor over and over and over
again
they're of a scale that's similar to
what the U.S Navy operates in submarines
or aircraft carriers these things are
super safe most importantly they use the
spent fuel from traditional nuclear
reactors so now you're actually using up
that old fuel so you don't have to go
dig up more uranium to make them operate
and they're very safe because if
something happens in one of these things
you're talking about an area of just
about a couple of Acres around it that
are potentially going to be irradiated
versus a whole city and so granted they
also generate less electricity 30
megawatts 50 megawatts but these are
perfect for solving the biggest problem
we have with the energy Grid in the US
today which is lack of transmission
lines you know you can build solar farms
in rural areas all day long you can
build wind farms all day long what's the
problem is you can't get that
electricity to where people live
all right bulk of the population of the
U.S lives east of the Mississippi most
of the solar generation is west of the
Mississippi transmission lines are
missing it's going to take hundreds of
billions of dollars to build the
transmission lines so you're much better
off putting energy generation next to
where the consumers are and California
today they're building lots of solar on
houses you have solar at the community
level you have batteries together with
that now the grid operators in
California can actually borrow
electricity from consumers battery Falls
when they need it to avoid brownouts do
that at industrial scale across the
country and now all of a sudden
transmission becomes less of an issue
and it's just the way the internet works
you put all the intelligence at the edge
of the network and you leave the network
as being kind of just dumb that's
exactly what we need to do with power
generation so smrs are a great solution
they're combined with solar and wind and
other renewable energy needs so as you
guys kind of go around the world are you
pushing into these other geographies are
you going out and seeking power
generation opportunities are you going
and trying to figure out where you kind
of fit in in these geographies or are
you being pulled are you getting phone
calls from whether it's governments or
private companies and they're saying hey
please please come here and there's
almost like a competition to get where
you're going to go open your next site
similar to how Amazon HQ kind of has a
competition among cities how how is that
uh from a push or a poll standpoint
it's definitely more of a poll situation
today uh you know after our success with
the UAE site you know uh we've gotten
calls from Qatar Oman uh Bhutan uh Kenya
and Africa
um Latin America countries there so it's
uh governments but it's also private
Enterprises you know there are people
who have the concession for energy in a
particular location and they want to
build out more capacity they don't have
off take for it and you know you don't
want to partner with somebody who's
gonna potentially have challenges
raising capital or executing and we've
proven that we are very good at raising
Capital we're mostly one of the best of
the publicly traded miners at raising
Capital
um we're also very good at executing and
very challenging conditions you know the
UAE site runs for the ambient
temperature is over 100 degrees every
single day pretty much and our pilot
site ran there for over 100 Days with no
human intervention
all right so when you can operate sites
with very little human intervention it
means you can put them in places where
they're very few humans
so you can put them in the Hinterlands
of deserts and places like that and
because the energy we consume
doesn't need to be transmitted to a
consumer
we can partner with people to build
these renewable sites in locations where
otherwise it would make no economic
sense to do it and as you look at things
like geothermal energy you can't move
that energy right you got to get it out
of the ground where it's available and
so those are sites that we think are
really interesting and we're also
looking at things like landfill gas you
know the methane gas that comes out of
landfills is 80 times more damaging to
the environment than carbon dioxide if
you can build small enough Bitcoin
mining site together with energy
generation at the landfill site you can
use that gas to create Bitcoin and you
can offset a lot of your energy
generating costs because of the
renewable energy credits you can
generate and that's part of our Tech
stack is to be able to build these small
totally automated self-contained Bitcoin
mining sites you can put out in the
field somewhere talk about one of the
other things I think you guys are really
focused on which is chasing the
non-parasitic load right so when you
think about this there's kind of the
zero cost energy you're talking about
renewable credits there's a bunch of
different strategies as to how you kind
of get here but explain maybe the way
that you all are approaching this in
this pursuit of that zero cost energy
and non-parasitic load
yeah so if you think about parasitic
load is you're sitting on the grid and
you're really competing with the
consumer in other Industries primarily
other Industries for energy and so you
have to curtail as a good citizen
um when the grid operator needs it if
you're sitting behind the meter
especially with a lot of renewable sites
they oftentimes have stranded energy if
you think about solar and wind it's the
top of the energy stack meaning it's the
first to be shut off and the last to be
turned on and if you think about solar
you know it shines 9 A.M to 3 P.M well
if you believe in the duck curve of
energy which is kind of when energy is
consumed it looks like the bottom of a
duck the belly is nine to three PM
that's when the least amount of energy
is used so solar sites get curtailed and
that's why in places like Texas you have
negative energy pricing upwards of 20 of
the time sometimes in that middle of the
day so weeks that for example in West
Texas on a large Wind Farm behind the
meter and when that wind farm isn't
selling energy into the grid we can
consume it all it's non-parasitic we're
not competing with the Grid or consumers
for that energy and if the grid needs it
we can give it up and so um it's a
different model than sitting on the grid
where you're competing for every
electron
as we continue to watch this uh industry
play out it seems like people are
building uh mining equipment mining
facilities and they're going and they're
seeking out the power do you envision a
world where people will say no this is
actually one single uh kind of facility
we're actually going to build ground up
from scratch power generation and the
facility you're talking about kind of
being behind the meter and going into
some of the existing Renewables but like
could someone build a wind farm
specifically for Bitcoin mining kind of
integrate everything from day one or are
we still a ways away from that
uh the answer is yes and it's happening
today and it's an area we're very
focused on right now
got it and when you think about that
strategy do you think that becomes the
majority of what people do or that's
just really difficult to do and only a
couple of companies will be able to so
most people just go seek out existing
power generation
so you know most Bitcoin mining today to
do it economically is done at utility
scale you know 50 megawatts 100
megawatts 200 megawatts because you got
to build a building or a field of
containers and you got to have people
there to operate it if you're going to
operate in a lot of these um
self-generating environments methane
flare gas for example in oil fields or
landfill gas or smaller solar Farms they
don't generate that much energy on a
consistent enough basis so you need to
be able to operate these things very
much as automated facility where there
aren't human beings and so you got to
have the technology to do that so I've
got tons of years in the world of iot
and Industrial Automation we have built
our Tech Stacks specifically for this
opportunity our next Generation
immersion technology will have three or
four times the compute power density of
existing Technologies today fully
self-contained no need for external
Cooling and will enable people to really
set these things up one go out to
megawatts three megawatts and operate
them very hands-off so we totally see
this as being one combined kind of unit
when you don't have those humans there
on site how does that change the unit
economics and maybe some of the
insulation you have from the cyclicality
of of Bitcoin or does it not matter
you know it doesn't change the
cyclicality because at the end of the
day you know we don't control the price
of Bitcoin we don't control Global hash
rate
um and then we have havings that happen
every four years so the goal is to lower
your marginal cost to produce a Bitcoin
as much as possible and so you do that
by finding the cheapest energy or
ideally zero cost energy and you do it
by sucking SG a out of your model and so
you think about these big sites you know
a company like a riot for example they
have hundreds of employees per site
um you know we're still a company with
sub 50 employees today and yet we're
arguably one of the biggest miners in
the world so our whole model is built on
optimizing RSG a and being as efficient
the minor as possible and so as we've
transitioned from being kind of this
acid light Miner who only work with
third parties to being more of an owned
and operated and moving to what we call
a zero cost energy model uh we believe
that you know that'll allow us to be
amongst the most low-cost energy uh or
low cost minor in the industry which
means that as the margins compress over
time in this industry uh you know it's
last man standing kind of gets the last
Bitcoin right it's um I don't do public
math but I think uh you're about 40
million dollars of market cap per
employee if you kind of use a metric
like that
um that is a an incredible statistic
compared to most businesses even in the
tech industry and so um is it something
where uh those are kind of fixed costs
and let's say 50 maybe even 100
employees is kind of you know the
plateau of what you'll need you can
scale infinitely or is there some linear
relationship between the team size and
as you bring more uh hash rate online
yeah so the biggest expenses obviously
your executive team your think of it
your knowledge workers right so the
engineers all have people that scales to
a certain level and you don't need to
scale it much bigger after that it
becomes
um what we call technicians right in the
field so the technicians who are the
people who build the sites get them
provisioned and operating and then
manage and service them and so if we can
have sites where we have minimal
unplanned downtime because we have
really good predictive systems we have
really good Management systems and tools
for looking at what's going to break
when and fixing it plus Building Systems
that are redundant then that technician
tier can be smaller and smaller and
smaller as we continue to scale and
that's where you really get the scale
Plus in some cases you work with
outsourced resources which could be very
low cost and
part of the attraction in the
international model is there are
opportunities to be at sites where
between Automation and the lower cost of
Labor there's just no other operator
that can compete Fred my last question
for you is if I had to ask you uh
Bitcoin miners Revenue hash rate and
then bitcoin price five years from now
is those three things up or down so
Bitcoin minor Revenue hash rate and
price of Bitcoin where do you see those
three metrics five years from now
well they all tie so much together so
um let's use is the point the having in
2028 right so as we come into that
having in 2028 uh I think what you're
going to see is the price of Bitcoin is
going to be somewhere in the low six
digits you know we're going to be 100 to
200 000 somewhere in that range most
probably
um conservatively speaking right Global
hash rate
close to 900 most probably
um and then minor revenues
um total Global revenues
um will obviously go up because the
price of Bitcoin has gone up uh but
total Bitcoin rewards will have had
almost twice by that point right so um
the expectation is you'll see revenues
most probably close to what they are
today but the difference is there'll be
a lot fewer miners you're going to have
a handful of very large miners that are
Global in scale that are quasi-energy
companies that may even be highly
Diversified in what they do not just
doing Bitcoin mining but doing other
data center type operations you know
some of our colleagues in the industry
are chasing HPC opportunities some are
chasing AI opportunities there are lots
of things that you could do as a minor
um and then you're going to have a bunch
of smaller specialist Niche operators
who you know they're particularly good
at dealing with Latin American jungles
and doing things in waterfalls uh you
know things like that that makes uh that
makes complete sense where can we send
people if they want to follow up with
you or they want to learn more about
what you all are doing
um so you know our website is mara.com
mara.com just like our stock symbol easy
to find and we're publishing more and
more data there uh on a regular basis
you can reach me on Twitter at f g t l t
h i e l and happy to answer questions
and interact with people there I always
enjoyed talking to you I learned so much
thank you and we'll definitely do it
again in the future
appreciate it thank you very much
[Music]